When you sit down and observe your own
mind on purpose just for fun,
um,
as a kind of
scientific inquiry into
what drives you,
it doesn't take long.
Say if you
focus on say the breath is the object of
attention and you're riding on the way
as you're breathing.
It doesn't take long before you'll
notice that I'm some kind of want to
comes up some kind of desire and maybe
it's because your body is uncomfortable,
so maybe you just want to fidget a
little or shift posture,
you know,
and just do it this way or that way.
And so very hard to sit still.
Why?
Because we're antsy.
Why are we answering?
Because we want to be comfortable and
we're not comfortable.
So rather than the holding the
discomfort
in awareness because why should we
privilege comfort,
comfort,
discomfort?
Because there is no ultimate comfort.
That's why we shift from one leg to the
other and we're always very shifty.
But if you actually train yourself to be
embodied,
you get less shifting.
I mean the mind just naturally settles.
The body naturally settles and you can
be comfortable
at home in your own skin,
but when you're not and you want
something,
we call that greed.
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
it's greedy at wants something now that
wanting to just be comfortable.
That's fine,
but when you start to watch the mind,
you'll notice that it's got a lot of
agendas on the greed spectrum.
I mean,
it,
it's an greed is not quite the same as
ambition.
It has to do with greed,
has to do with more for me,
more of what I want from me.
Then there's this other thing that
you'll also notice,
which is you're sitting there and uh,
the opposite will come up.
What I don't want,
what I'm afraid of,
what I need to keep at the door.
Keep at bay to push a way.
And uh,
that's collectively referred to as
aversion or dislike or hatred.
You know,
when it's really strong and direct the
dolphin that other people or whatever,
you know.
So we've got greed on the one hand and
it is toxic.
The more you're sucked into greed,
the more go testicle you become,
the more it's all about me,
the more you're willing to sort of lose
your own ethical foundation to get a
particular result only to find that even
that results not really satisfying.
So you're onto the next result and it's
a never ending trajectory.
But nevertheless have to admit it's here
all the time.
It's not like,
oh,
I've transcended greed,
you know,
I don't think we do transcend greed,
but we can transform how we are in
relationship to it.
And with awareness,
the greed doesn't have to run us.
And even if it's attenuated five or 10
percent,
wow.
That would be its own form of
liberation,
nevermind.
Thirty or 40 or 50 percent.
And the same with the aversion,
like what I don't want.
It's so bloody boring to sit here and
watch my breathing.
All right,
so what,
who thinks it's boring?
Uh,
have you looked at your boredom?
So have you looked at your aversion then
as soon as the you that's looking at
your revision,
that's more like awareness.
Awareness of aversion isn't diversive.
Awareness of greed isn't greedy.
So you're free already have those too,
toxic impulses.
Then there's another one which is like
the madness that passes for
the scenario in our heads and that's
often spoken of as illusion or delusion
that we're kind of like got these
completely half baked explanations about
everything and who we are and where
things are going and what's wrong with
the world and what's wrong with my
family and what's right and all of that
is Kinda.
None of it's true.
None of it's true,
but we believe it that that narrative
mode and that mind wandering default
mode network,
that's like my favorite pastime,
the story of me and it's diluted and it
also drains a huge amount of energy so
we can bring mindfulness to greed and
the greed can be attenuated or
liberated.
Mindfulness to a version and the version
can be attenuated,
deliberate or mindfulness to our own
diluted nature,
thoughts and emotions and so forth,
and that is liberating of them.
Then what do you have left
you
as pure awareness,
fully embodied what comes next?
I don't know.
You're writing the script.
It's not like,
oh,
then you'll feel this and you'll feel
that and you'll be enlightened and
everybody will bow down to you and you
know you will never have to have any
kind of challenges or difficulty.
The full catastrophe will evaporate
forever.
No,
it'll be the same old,
same old,
only you won't be the same old.
Same because you,
oh,
you'll be the same.
You'll have the same bank account.
You'll have the same social security
number.
You have the same face in the mirror.
It'd be aging everyday,
but you will be in wiser relationship to
your possibilities
and to your embodied
enacted unfolding of those possibilities
moment by moment,
and that means life lived fully.
Wow.
You have a chance while we have the
chance,
as far as I know you didn't ask to be
born this pure gravy.
It's just a total gift.
Even with all the pain and suffering and
the trauma,
and I recognize the profundity of that
and the rendering quality of the still.
It's.
It's a gift and your gift and
silence in some sense at that point
becomes
wakefulness.
It's radiant,
it's luminous,
and it's already you.